Sam Brinton was not the only guy who
dressed in weird
vaguely satanic sometimes not so vaguely
satanic ways in the Biden Administration
you remember the deputy chief of the
monkey pox response Demetrios something
or other was this guy
who
photographed himself flaunted himself
wearing all sorts of satanic imagery not
just leather and whips and chains
pentagrams on his chest a pentagram
leather harness on top of a pentagram
tattoo that the guy put on his chest
you think what is it with this why is it
that we're watching the Grammys and Sam
Smith is dancing around like a kind of
millennial lesbian Satan figure dancing
and jiggling around with all these kind
of demonic looking transsexuals around
him everybody is applauding the first
lady of the United States is in the
audience applauding
why do we see all of this imagery why
are are the the Liberals in New York
raising an actual demon statue on top of
a courthouse in Madison Square why are
they doing that
what what is it about the Symmetry and
then yesterday I see on the cover of
Vogue Italy
Gisele Bundchen Giselle the former Mrs
Brady she's just divorced Tom Brady
Gisele Bundchen considered one of the
most beautiful women in the world and
look at this picture she's
unrecognizable
and what is the picture of it's her in
all red and her her skin is colored all
white just white as a corpse then red
all over her lips her hair is dyed
bright red fiery red as it's being
described in the In Articles a really
really dark around the eyes fiery red
eyebrows
and then
if you look at her head you realize her
head is placed right between the O and
the g
so that you have an almost perfectly
symmetrical lines coming from the O and
the g that are in the placement of and
in the shape of horns and then you look
at her arms and her hand placement and
her arms and her hand placement are in
this very strange way her right arm is
pointed up her hands are in this her
fingers are in this kind of odd
Direction and then her left hand is
pointed to the side not quite down but
certainly further down than
the right arm
and I don't I don't think I'm going too
far down the rabbit hole here to say
this is a demonic pose everything about
in it not just it's demonic
in a pretty uh identifiable way with one
of the most famous depictions of a demon
that would be eliphos levees drawing of
Baphomet many people have seen it
probably the most well-known occult
image and it's of this demon with horns
coming out of his head in the same shape
and with wings behind him that are that
we see mirrored on this red dress that
Gisele Bundchen is wearing because the
dress has these kind of wings that come
out of it the arms are in not exactly
the same position but a very similar
position almost the same the picture of
Baphomet is a kind of transgender
picture it's of a goat head and then
breasts a woman's torso and then a male
rest of the body as I'm I made the point
that Media Matters made fun of me four
weeks ago but my publicists were right
were really helpful I think in putting
this out there because it was obviously
a true observation that many traditional
depictions of the Demonic are
androgynous and sort of trans and the
question that you got to ask yourself
even if you think all this is really
bizarre and you're not religious and you
don't believe in any of this stuff is
okay let's say let's just pretend for a
second God doesn't exist there's no such
thing as good or evil devil doesn't
exist okay let's pretend all of that
why do all these people dress this way
why do all these people in positions of
power accepted by the liberal culture
why do they all use the exact same
symbolism which is ancient symbolism
which is for
the devil it's it's kind of weird even
if you don't believe in any of this you
never go to church you gotta at least
notice that strange coincidence
that all of these people who are
enthralled to the powers and
principalities of this world they all
use the same images it all looks like
demons I you know I'm like the guy on
the History Channel there's that guy who
he's trying to explain seemingly
inexplicable phenomena that are a little
bit off he'll say well it's it's aliens
it's kind of like that now for me except
it it's demons is what it is
there's an old line from baudelaire
which is the greatest trick the devil
ever played is to convince us that he
doesn't exist
that might be old I think that might
that might be over
that was true
it was true for the scientific post
Enlightenment era
I think the exact quote it's in French
but a good translation is the finest
trick the devil played is to convince
you he doesn't exist
that that is what happened for the last
300 years
before the last 300 years everybody
thought the devil exists and every
culture on Earth for all of human
history
for the last 300 years the devil kind of
went into hiding why did the devil go
into hiding well because
scientism accomplished his goals I think
better than he could scientism convinced
people that God doesn't exist and so the
devil kind of went away but you're
noticing now that there are many more
overt depictions of this weird occult
kind of behavior
why is that I suspect it's because
people are losing their faith in science
I suspect it's because you're seeing the
the tyranny of the fauces of the world
start to crack the authority of modern
Medical Science to give Perfectly
Natural explanations for all the sorts
of phenomena we see that's breaking down
a little bit so I think the devil's
becoming a little more brazen
that's what you can call me crazy but
explain to me all these weird depictions
in fact speaking of the occult and
politics we've got a new presidential
candidate not on the Republican side but
on the Democrat side that would be
Marianne Williamson you might remember
Marianne Williamson she ran in 2020 on
the Democrat side and she became most
well known for her description of what's
really going on in the political scene
I assure you I lived in Gross Point what
happened in Clint would not have
happened in Gross Point this is part of
the dark underbelly of American society
the racism the bigotry and the entire
conversation that we're having here
tonight if you think any of this
wonkiness is going to deal with this
dark psychic force of the collectivized
hatred that this President is bringing
up in this country then I'm afraid that
the Democrats are going to see some very
dark days we need to say it like it is
it's bigger than Flint it's all over
this country
that was the line that she got made fun
of for the most but actually it was the
most coherent line that Marianne
Williamson's probably ever said she said
there are dark psychic forces at Play
yeah that's basically true yeah of
course there's a spiritual reality under
girding physical phenomena and there are
dark psychic forces dark spiritual
forces at least in politics now the
problem with Marianne Williamson is
she's on the wrong side of it she's one
of these new age occult type people
but she is recognizing it
she's she's definitely closer to the
truth than the agnostic atheist type
people who say there's no such thing as
metaphysical or spiritual reality well
she's in the race now she says I
wouldn't be running
for president if I didn't believe I
could contribute to harnessing the
collective sensibility that I feel is
our greatest hope at this time
and so all this new agey weird talk but
I'm glad to see her in the race she was
one of my favorite characters from 2020
and I seriously like Beyond just how
entertaining she is I like that she
reminds people that as Cardinal Manning
pointed out all human conflicts
certainly all politics is ultimately
religious the rest of the show
continues now
we are going into fake headline Friday
I need your help help me identify the
fake headline among the real headlines
of Mr Davies has given me you don't want
to miss it go to dailyword.com
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
[Music]